what's the deal with airplane peanuts
everyone sitting in the front row at the
LA improv last week got a whole lot more
than they paid for after comedian
Natasha leero followed Burke Ker's
shirtless Antics on stage with an
impromptu strip teas of her
[Applause]
own after the insane crowd reaction
Natasha performed the the rest of her
set bare chested with a jacket partially
covering her cans leaving the crowd and
fellow comedians completely stunned in
the video posted by TMZ you can even
hear Bert yelling I got to take my pants
off now I got to take my pants off
now the night after this all went down
in California Natasha took to her
Instagram to share these photos from her
topless show with the caption reading
Bert took his shirt off so I did too
improv said not to post but TMZ already
did so f it should female Comics be able
to do the same same thing as male Comics
because I've also been thinking about
trying to my opener male Comics are
always coming up to me and they're like
hey
Natasha don't you think you're a little
attractive to be a comedian and I'm like
don't you think you're a little ugly to
be talking to
me after reading her quote on Instagram
about the rules for male vers female
Comics the mainstream media has begun to
spin Natasha's viral moment into a
stance for women attacking double
standards in comedy which is a pretty
strange argument to make because when it
comes to being topless on stage I think
it's safe to assume Almost 100% of
female comedians would prefer to not get
naked on stage and if anything Natasha's
stunt proved that technically women can
feel free to strip on stage just like
male comics in fact they'll end up
getting even more attention the other
explanation might sound even crazier
considering that Bert and Natasha are
good friends but there is a chance that
this impulsive moment happened after
Natasha saw that Bert Cher was shirtless
when calling her on on stage and if she
hasn't seen Bert perform often and
didn't know that it was his thing to
always be shirtless this may have just
been a spontaneous way to keep the
energy up after following Bert simply
going topless for Good Vibes now it does
seem unlikely that these two longtime La
comedians are not familiar enough with
each other for Natasha to know that Bert
takes his shirt off at every show but
then again she also had somehow never
heard the machine story even while it
was being turned into a blockbuster film
so it's safe to assume Natasha lero is
no Bert expert I wasn't a drinker until
I got in involved with the Russian mafia
I was not a drinker at all you're
involved with the Russian mafia no you
never heard that story I'll tell you the
story the uh the are you really yeah you
know that story no Bert I don't know
this you're in the Russian MAF but are
you supposed to not say anything no no
no not when I got involved when I went
to Russia I went to Russia when I was 22
you know this story and I robbed a train
you've never what wait is a [__] what
is this is so good this is you're the
one person what well you know you know
my nickname the machine right no B are
you serious oh this is awesome sweet are
you being okay so yeah so I want okay
hang on hang on so you know that like I
drink a lot right I mean I gathered that
because you said it stopped working okay
no like we touched on at the beginning
of this video there's now been hundreds
of Articles written over KN that are
trying to use this event to make a
larger stance about unfair double
standards towards women in comedy using
Natasha's Instagram caption should
female Comics be able to do the same
thing as male Comics as fuel for their
fire comparing Bert taking a shirt off
to women being treated unfairly in
comedy doesn't make a whole lot of sense
however because if a female comic wanted
to become the next Bert crer and started
only performing shirtless those shows
would sell out in literal seconds she
would end up with a bigger tour than
Bert doing 100 City Arena tours where
the AUD audience is all full of dudes
not paying attention to a single joke
basically the female version of Matt R
but even just thinking about what
happens at Matt R shows is insane and
he's a guy with his shirt on like some a
girl will yell out in the middle of a
show like me or something wild the
people yell at these shows whatever
prompted This Magic Moment at the LA
improv it definitely got more eyes on
Natasha's standup and after now making
multiple Instagram posts about the whole
situation it doesn't seem to have any
real downsides from her point of view it
is highly doubtful that this will become
her new thing but I'm sure she's gained
more than a handful of new fans along
the way when people go why do you take
your shirt off no one asked me that when
I'm in Florida they go yeah he takes a
shirt cuz they they have their shirts
off too dude that's what you do [__]
gets out of control you rip your [__]
shirt off that's what you [__] do
guest spots from last week Joe Rogan had
on Yannis papis Joey Diaz and a fight
companion two bears one cave was Burt
and Jake Johnson killed Tony this week
was with Derek Poston and Assad we might
be drunk did not have a guest Robert
Kelly was on areu garbage AR Sha be was
a guest on Whiskey Ginger Trevor Wallace
was on tiger belly Carmen Lynch was on
the Giannis Papa hour bad friends had on
Rudy and her sister and Y Mage spoke
with Sam Talent would you rather have a
huge [__] like the [__] of your dreams
but you're short for a man whatever that
is like both experiences would be brand
new for me that's right you're tall I'm
huge you're small yeah S four 74 huge
yeah or would you be um so this and
you're short but you're or be super tall
like tall or have a small one been
there yeah I want a different I want a
different ride
yeah if you're 410 and you have like a
parking cone a pie you're going to be
able to you're going to be famous
they're going to put you in movies and
everyone's going to talk about you even
if you go I don't want this to get out
guess what it's getting out everyone's
going to be your friends your guy
friends are going to be like [__]
little Samy's dick is crazy it is nuts
this past weekend with theovon hasn't
posted since the Shane episode Cole
Beasley was on Matt and Shane secret
podcast Bert ker was on the brand new
Wayback podcast hosted by Ryan sickler
the bloxs podcast had on Heather McMahon
being in with Jordan welcome Todd Barry
Brandon Wardell and Patrick Doran
visited stav's World Brad Williams was
on you know what dude Chad Daniels went
on Soder and Shane Torres was on only
fans as far as new stand-up comedy
specials are either out right now or
coming out soon Dusty slay's debut
Netflix special titled working man is
out right now and everyone seems to be
really enjoying that one we also have
Andy Haynes the suggested comedy special
out on YouTube along with Dez Bishop of
all people in addition Josh Wolf posted
an hour and 12 minute video titled the
full bachelor party set and Tony Casas
just released a mini special on YouTube
titled Millennial man the one sport I am
good at the one sport I am good at is
bowling I'm good at
bowling no one respects my sport you
civilians use bowling as a date night I
can't take a girl on a date bowling I
get to too into it I bring my balls I
wear the glove halfway through she's
like what if we put up bumpers i'm like
[__] my name's on the wall people know
me
here you see Barb in the corner smoking
a cigarette through a neck hole
surprisingly she talks you know I don't
need to show up on my Monday league and
she's like I saw Tony bll with
bumpers what a
[__] so how about you throw a ball cuz
I ain't getting hard right now
[__] also few specials in the works
right now Jeff Dunham I'm with cupid is
coming out on February 3rd on Comedy
Central followed by Taylor Tomlinson
have it all which premieres globally on
Netflix February 13th and Mike EPS has a
brand new special coming out February
20th titled ready to sell out be sure to
follow joke World on Instagram and check
the link in that bio to get some free
joke World stickers sent your way and if
you've already claimed your free
stickers and want more ways to represent
the channel feel free to check out our
merch store using the link in the
description of this video below keep an
eye out for a few more videos is coming
out this week along with the best of
January in just 8 Days thanks for
watching at joke
World it
world and it world is wld
D that's a great uh YouTube channel joke
World check it out